gut schneiden kümmerlich ich will auch
nichts vormachen
meine freundin ist 24 sie es viele jahre
älter als ich hey leute was gedacht
herzlich willkommen
so was geht ab jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video habe ich das jetzt schon
gesagt keine ahnung auf jeden fall ich
komme direkt auf den punkt ich habe
letztens vor seiner zuschauerinnen auf
instagram habe ich so ein link bekommt
ja irgendwie so ein quiz für mich
erstellt und da ist mir aufgefallen es
gibt schon mehrere quiz ist auf jeden
fall also über mich halt so quiz und da
habe ich mir gedacht ja kommen macht sie
doch einfach mal mit euch zusammen als
ich habe jetzt 1 rausgesucht das ist
alles ganz witzig und ja die ersten
beiden fragen kann ich jetzt hier schon
sehen ich würde sagen da sind aber noch
ein paar mehr dabei und wir machen das
jetzt mal zusammen mal gucken was bei
rauskommt alex wie wie gut kennst du ihn
also wie gut kenne ich mich selber dann
müsste ja eigentlich alles richtig sein
wenn ich dann welche nicht wenn ihr
öfter so was sehen wollt könnt ihr gern
mal nach oben gelassen ich bei euch auch
mal diese seite in die beschreibungen da
machen viele so halt youtube zuschauerin
oder zuschauer über irgendwelche
youtuber quiz ihr könnt auch gern mal
recht über mich machen wie die schicken
und dann mache ich vielleicht auch mal
dieses chris von euch dann also seid
creative schickten das zu irgendwo
instagram snapshot keine ahnung ist auch
alles in der video beschreibung
wir fangen an und ich bin heftig
gespannt okay leute wären ja alex wie
wie gut kennst du ihn alex wie youtube
was auf erste fragen wie groß ist alex
175 12 19 180 habe ich das überhaupt
schon mal irgendein video gesagt das
finde ich immer richtig crazy so es gibt
einfach menschen die wissen mehr über
mich also was heißt mehr über mich aber
die wissen dinge wo ich gar nicht weiß
dass ich die mal gesagt hab aber ich bin
180 so nächste frage wählten seine
eltern ihn genannt wäre er ein mädchen
geworden chantal hat klar
alexandra oder lava lara glaub ich
welche haarfarbe hat er zurzeit
hellblond was habe ich das halt gelb
oder ist er geld pink oder blau ja das
ist auch ideell blond was mögen die
meisten abonnenten am liebsten sein
lachen seine augen wenn er sich im video
auszieht alles klar
keine ahnung was mögt ihr geld am
liebsten schreibt so in die kommentare
also an die weiblichen zuschauer
abonnenten ach so herr niemann nicht
mehr jetzt bist du scheiße also an die
weiblichen zuschauer was mögt ja mir
mein lachen meine augen
da werde ich mich ausziehe ich mag am
liebsten natürlich wenn ich mich
ausziehe nein keine angst da weiß ich
jetzt echt nicht was ich sagen soll
oder sein lachen belasten würde ich mich
ausziehe
wie nennt alex jedes mädchen in seinen
videos ja schon teil oder chantal
klatschen teil und da auch mal eine
kleine info zu ich hab nichts gegen
stadtteil ich finds halt nur irgendwie
war es nicht gerade passt immer kann man
immer verwenden deswegen chantal ganz
einfach so wie altes alex finden
18 wie kommst du auf diese warum hat es
alex vor 18 624 weißt du das in sein
richtiger playern ich weiß jetzt gar
nicht wieder auf die frage kommt also
von den antworten ist alles falsch alles
morgen ist euro rabatt gutschein kann
alex ich will euch auch nichts vormachen
meine freundin ist 24 ließ viele jahre
älter als ich aber ist doch geil aber
nicht wie lange macht alexion youtube
circa zwei jahre vor zwei jahren habe
ich ja letztlich glaube ich auch in
meinem video gesagt welches soziale
netzwerk hat alex nicht instagram snap
du bist aber auch nicht so gut
informiert
also ich habe schon alle sozialen
netzwerke davon allerdings benutzt
twitter nicht also twitter finde ich
irgendwie eher ein bisschen langweilig
ist nicht so mein ding das werk in
welcher stadt wohnt alex sonderfrage bei
crysis finde ich immer leiser sei nicht
wissen oder als das quiz christopher
clark wissens sonne frage für mich immer
total einfach weil guck mal das muss ja
bielefeld seine weil münchen hat so
viele einwohner hamburg hat so viele
einwohner und was bitte bielefeld wird
jetzt stehen münchen hamburg oder berlin
wird schwer aber wir nehmen jetzt
bielefeld weil ich wohl noch in
bielefeld ich weiß nicht ob ihr auch in
bielefeld wohnt
wenn ihr bock hab das mal so ein treffen
in bielefeld mache ich jetzt mal
überlegt mit einem kumpel dann könnt ihr
das hier mal in die kommentare schreiben
so und die letzten letzte fragestunde
scheiße was mag alex bei mädchen am
liebsten ich bin jetzt gerade die fragen
durch gedanken im kopf und macht mir so
keine ahnung vor habe ich das bitte
gesagt gute kurse von oberflächlich oder
das kann ich ja nicht bringen das dass
sie blond ist wo habe ich das gesagt ich
weiß es nicht das jeweils sich selbst
lachen kann all das habe ich mal gesagt
aber ich will natürlich gute kurven
etwas
wir nehmen das sie über sich selber
lachen können so leute und jetzt bin ich
gespannt das war nur zehn fragen aber
ich bin mal gespannt was rauskommt was
glaubt ihr ich sage ich schreibe jetzt
meine kommentare was glaubt ihr wie viel
habe ich richtig
ich sage ich hab mal ein paar sachen da
wusste ich echt nicht wie du darauf
kommst
ich sage ich habe sieben sachen richtig
auswerten
sie haben neun von zehn aufgaben richtig
beantwortet im durchschnitt haben die
vier servers chris cooper hey warum man
das schon viele leute gemacht eigentlich
hätte ich zwar zehn von zehn haben
müssen aber neun von zehn ist auch okay
glaub ich dann kenne ich mich halt mich
so gut
übrigens sexy bildern sehr gut du bist
toll dankeschön ja heute das war's mit
dem videofahrzeug gefallen hat wirklich
sehr freuen wenn ihr dort nach oben da
last ja wenn ihr sowas hab ich ja gesagt
macht einfach so ein paar crysis oder
quizz keine ahnung und schickt mir die
dann machen wir die auch mal demnächst
und seit wenig kreativ ihr könnt ihr
wirklich komplett bescheuert fragen
raushauen
das macht natürlich umso witziger wir
sehen uns dann schon morgen wieder jetzt
kommt er fast täglich im video ich habe
ja sogar zeit dazu und ich habe bock
drauf
und ja wir haben längst auch weiter mit
meinem ex video oder ist hier links ich
weiß es nicht irgendwo hier geht es
weiter der letzten station des jahres
angemeldet haben ein bis morgen und ich
komme ich gar nicht dran